reddit may just become the next big meme  stock or snoozer stock in any case it's  about to become a stock to bet on and it  could happen as soon as march and that's  because the social media company that  played such a key role in last year's  meme stock frenzy is getting ready to go  public itself bloomberg has just learned  that reddit hired morgan stanley and  goldman sachs for an initial public  offering this is after the company filed  the initial ipo paperwork back in  december according to people familiar  with the matter reddit may be valued at  up to 15 billion dollars the company  makes money by selling advertising and  is now looking to expand its audio and  video offerings because ad rates there  are higher  [Music]